well here in germany two suspects are
being held for the killing of two police
officers who were shot dead during a
traffic stop prosecutors believe the
hunters shot deadly officers to avoid
being caught for poaching a legal game
the case has caused widespread outrage
the two suspects were arrested on monday
evening police searching their homes
found a large number of guns among them
they believe the weapons that took the
lives of two young police officers
the main suspect a 38 year old man known
as a trader in wild game has so far
remained silent the other man a 32 year
old has admitted poaching but why such
deadly violence occurred remains unclear
prosecutors say the two officers were
both shot in the head
the female officer still had her pistol
in its holster
she may have had a flashlight in her
hand and the papers she cannot have seen
it coming
the officers were on patrol on a country
road when the fatal incident happened
they found a number of dead animals in a
vehicle and were speaking with the
occupants when they were shot
they called for help but by the time
their colleagues arrived it was too late
even seasoned investigators say they've
been shocked by the killings
it's not our idea of germany that
someone just starts shooting on the
street with hunting weapons and opens
fire just because he might be caught
poaching that's why this case is so
disturbing
the swing
is
prosecutors say there does not appear to
be any political motive behind this
crime the premier of the state of
rhineland-palatinate where the shooting
took place expressed her dismay at the
deaths
police every day police officers are on
the streets for us everywhere to protect
society and to be there for the
community
those who attack these officers are
attacking the whole of society
the younger police officer was just 24
years old and still completing her
training when she died that fact can
only heighten the sense of disbelief
across germany at this tragic loss of
life